Der 14. Spieltag in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Er ist gespielt, der November ist vorbei. Wir wollen auf die 2. Liga schauen und das mit Anna Lautenbach und Michael Fischer. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ja, willkommen zurück zur Ligatour, zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ihr könnt mich sonst in meinen Freunden am Abendpodcast hören oder in der Sendung von Heute Morgen zur Bundesliga der Männer. Witzig. Ja, aber mache heute den Podcast-Hat-Trick voll und deshalb auch der kleine, aber feine Hinweis, wenn ihr mich hier zwischendurch mal kurz husten seht oder so, es ist so die Kombination aus Winter, Derby und dritter Podcast heute tue nicht das Beste für meine Stimme. Von daher bin ich da etwas, ja, angekratzt. Aber ich muss ja glücklicherweise diese Sendung nicht alleine machen, sondern ich begrüße euch und meine Gäste zur letzten regulären Folge mit All-Star-Teammitgliedern in diesem Jahr. Was es damit auf sich hat, das erkläre ich euch gleich noch. Und damit welcome back an Anna Lautenbach vom Gegengarde Podcast. Hallo Anna.
Aber man muss ja auch sagen, der EV konnte 2000 neue Mitglieder gewinnen. Also rein von der Größe von Fürth her ist das, glaube ich, auch, ich meine, auch mit Mitgliedern kann man zumindest für den EV durch Mitgliederbeiträge ein bisschen Geld generieren. Und ich glaube, das ist schon mal gut. Und wenn ich es auch richtig gelesen habe, es waren so viele Teilnehmerinnen bei der JHV wie noch nie mit über 500.
590, ja, also fast 600 schon, ja.
Also ich glaube, da waren im Bielefeld weniger.
Das hat natürlich mit der sportlichen Krise auch zu tun. Noch ganz kurz dazu, es gab einen offenen Brief der Fanszene, den würde ich jetzt gar nicht groß zitieren, da wurden viele Fragen gestellt und man hat sich große Sorgen gemacht. Und der Verein hat darauf geantwortet und hat die JHV als ersten Austausch dazu auserkoren. Deswegen waren da wahrscheinlich auch sehr viele Menschen da, die aufgrund der sportlichen Situation kommen wollten. Aber ja, man hat den Fürzig lang gesträubt gegen neue Mitglieder und Mitgliederinnen. Und jetzt klappt es, aber der Großteil davon ist tatsächlich in der Fan-Abteilung eingetreten, die auf knapp 2000 Leute mittlerweile angewachsen ist. Also weil halt viele einfach diesen Vereinsnamen ändern wollen. Das ist ein riesiges Thema in Fürth, das kann man außerhalb von Fürth immer schwerlich begreifen. Aber ich bin auch in Fürth geboren, in meinem Ausfall steht Fürth. Und wenn ich dann auswärts bin und der Stadionsprecher sagt, wie glaube ich in Bielefeld auch und auf Schalke, aus Kräuter Fürth, dann sage ich, nein, das steht nicht in meinem Ausweis, ich komme aus Fürth und nicht aus Kräuter Fürth. Deswegen geht es ja auch um andere elementare Dinge, wie Identität und Verbundenheit zu einem Verein. Also es würde noch viel weitergehen. Und wenn Fürth was fehlt, dann ist es gerade Identität als sportliche Art, aber auch insgesamt als Verein. Insofern finde ich das auch unterstützenswert, dieses Thema. Aber man sollte erst mal jetzt das Sportliche in den Griff kriegen. Es ist deutlich dringender.
Also ich kann aus Erfahrung sagen, es ist immer wichtig, wenn Fans das Gefühl haben, sie kriegen auch eine Stimme. Also beziehungsweise, ich meine, klar kann dann auch ein Verein sagen, ja hier, dann kommt doch zum Mitgliederversammlung, dann können wir darüber reden. Und dann taucht halt keiner auf. Also es zeigt ja auch, dass eben den Fürtheren dieser Verein nicht egal ist. Und das mag vielleicht manchen Spielern auf dem Platz dann relativ egal sein. Aber so schlecht, wie die finanzielle Situation ist. Aber ich meine, wenn Stefan Führsner erst wochenlang sagt, nee, nee, also hier, ich gehe hier nicht von meiner Entscheidung weg. Und dann halt doch irgendwann auch sagt, okay, aber so geht es nicht weiter. Das wird auch andere Gründe haben. Wir wissen immer nie, was so ein Aufsichtsrat da auch noch rein zu sagen hat. Bzw. Michi weiß im Zweifel schon, ich von außen jetzt nicht. Das klingt dann immer so doof, aber es ist vielleicht dann doch so ein Segway rein in, es kann vielleicht noch besser werden. Also 37 Gegentore ist eine Hypothek. Das ist ungefragt so und man muss leider auch sagen, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man zwölf davon abziehen könnte und sagen könnte, die kriegen sie halt auch so einfach. Ich glaube, selbst laut XG sind sie da leider nicht so ganz weit von entfernt, von dem, was sie hätten bekommen sollen.
Und sie sind nach XG, also nach Expected Goals Against die schlechtesten und nach Expected Goals die schlechtesten. Das sind auch das keine guten Werte und nach Expected Points über diese Metri kann man ja auch streiten. Sie sind auch die schlechteste Mannschaft der Liga und damit auch auf Platz 18. Damit nähert man sich halt einfach dem an, was auch statistisch so ist. Ich wurde dafür oft angefallen, so den Fürth, wenn ich Statistiken angeführt habe, aber wir haben ja alle gelernt, dass es die berühmte Regression zur Mitte gibt. Und wenn man halt in allem schlecht ist, dann ist man irgendwann auch faktisch in allem schlecht. Und das ist man halt jetzt leider gerade– wir könnten noch so viel reden über Fürth, aber ich glaube, wir müssen einfach warten, was der Psycho-Vogel da mit anfängt. Ich habe ein bisschen ganz leichte Alexander Zorniger-Wipes. Da stand es ja auch ganz schlecht um Fürth. Da war man auf Platz 18 und dann kam ein erfahrener Trainer, der im Ausland mal Erfolge hatte mit Brünnbi und Liemersoll. Und dann hat man– Eva, du erinnerst dich vielleicht, das erste Spiel gegen eine gewisse Arminia aus Bielefeld gleich gewonnen und danach noch zwei weitere Spiele und dann noch mal in Braunschweig und dann zu Hause noch gegen den HSV und einen unentschiedenen Darmstadt und zack, hatte man zehn Punkte mehr. Das geht jetzt nicht mehr bis zur Winterpause. Aber wir wissen alle, ein Spiel gegen einen angeschlagenen Asniff zu Nürnberg, bei dem der beste Torschütze fehlt, bei dem vielleicht der Sechser ausfällt, ein neuer Trainer in Fürth. Ich will nicht zu viel Euphorie haben, weil es ist Fürth, aber damit kann man natürlich auch ein Statement setzen und damit würde auch man mehr als eine Trendumkehr schaffen. Derby letzte Saison haben wir oft genug betont 0 zu 4, 0 zu 3. Alle Fürther haben das ins Mark getroffen. Wenn man da in Nürnberg mindestens mal nicht verliert, mit guter Leistung vielleicht einen Punkt holt oder sogar gewinnt, dann sieht die Stimmungslage schon wieder anders aus. Dann kommt zwar die Hertha. Die ist ziemlich gut, aber dann spielt man auch bei Fortuna Düsseldorf. Damit könnte ich dir jetzt auch eine Brücke bauen, Eva. Aber ich wollte noch ganz kurz auch etwas über die Haufei Bochum sagen. Genau. Ich war gespannt. Oder willst du Anna erst oder soll ich noch mein Monolog fortsetzen?
Ich kann gerne ein bisschen was sagen. Ja, mach doch mal. Obwohl, will ich jetzt schon was sagen? Also ich finde, Uwe Rösler hat ja zu einem sehr ähnlichen Datum wie einen Trainer seinen Amt übernommen, über den wir heute auch noch sprechen werden. Und es ist so ein bisschen das erfolgreiche Gegenstück. Und beides freut mich, muss ich sagen. Also der Erfolg des einen, aber no offence, auch der Misserfolg des anderen. Ja, genau. Und möchte sagen, weil wir ja viel so Referenzen ziehen zu den Vereinen, die wir am besten kennen, worum sich da langfristig unten nicht und warum sich die langfristig da unten nicht, weil sie Standards einfach zu Toren machen. Das ist nicht besonders wunderschön. Und vielleicht nicht so der spielerische Weg raus, wie ihn Magdeburg anstrebt, aber brutal effektiv, also nur einmal verloren. Und also seit Uwe Rösler im Amt ist. Und ich glaube, dass sie da eine gute Entscheidung getroffen haben. Und dass sie da mittelfristig, wenn sie die Nerven weiter behalten, relativ zügig den Weg auch rausfinden.
Ja, da hat man auch ganz klar gesehen jetzt in Fürth. Also diese Freistöße von Maxi Wittek, die waren wirklich, also es war jeder Standard wurde gefährlich, weil allein schon der Schütze einen gefährlichen Standard fabriziert hat. Ich erinnere mich an einen Verein, den ich da auch abspielen sehen, bei dem die meisten Standards nicht gefährlich werden, weil die Schüsse schon oder die Flanken und Heringaben schon nicht gut sind. Also da hat man einen guten Standardschütze, man hat natürlich auch Spieler mit einer gewissen Größe. Wenn Philipp Hofmann den spielt, er hat den auch nicht immer gespielt in diesem Spiel, hat er gespielt. Sissoko hat wieder nach langer Ausfallzeit zum ersten Mal wieder vom Beginn an gespielt, hat auch eine gute Größe. Also man hat da Spieler, man wird es natürlich nicht jede Woche so leicht haben, wie in Fürth Tore zu schießen nach Standards, aber man hat es eben gemacht und damit hat man ja mit den ersten zwei Standard-Toren nach 13 Minuten war das Spiel eigentlich entschieden, dass das dritte noch kam, hat dann den Deckel drauf gemacht, aber Fürth wäre auch nach 0-2 nicht mehr zurückgekommen. Dafür ist zu vieles kaputt gegangen hier. Und ich fand sie auch ansonsten sehr stabil. Also klar, sie mussten nicht mehr viel machen, weil Fürth auch nichts mehr gemacht hat, kamen den Buche mal ganz gelegen, weil sie ein Pokalspiel unter der Woche haben. Also konnten sie sich dafür auch schonen, mussten glaube ich nur 113 Kilometer laufen oder so. Also für zweitig her verhältnis jetzt gar nicht mal so viel. Und ansonsten auch, wie Anna schon sagte, Uwe Rösler hat, glaube ich, vier von sechs Spielen gewonnen, einmal unentschieden, einmal verloren, dann hat er das gewonnen, auch drei der letzten vier Spiele gewonnen. Dazwischen diese, warum auch immer, nicht erklärbare Niederlage gegen Dynamo Dresden, auf die wir gleich auch noch kommen. Aber ansonsten sieht es trotzdem stabil aus. Interessant doch bei Bochum, dass man ja schon einen gewissen Jugendstil hat. Und Jeka zum Beispiel hat jetzt auch wieder gespielt, da gibt es auch andere Spieler noch. Ich will gar nicht alle aufzählen, aber man hat dann auch vielversprechende Talente hochgezogen, die mittlerweile beim VfL spielen. Junge Elan, der dann mit dazu gekommen ist, gepaart mit der Erfahrung, die man hat mit Hofmann, mit Wittek, mit natürlich auch Holtmann noch, der sich in Fürth leider verletzt hat, mit Noah Losli, der letztes Jahr in Fürth noch teilweise auch wirklich gute Spiele gemacht hat in der Abwehr, Strompf als Hühner, der in der Abwehr da hinten drin steht, letztes Jahr noch in Ulm, der aber auch offensiv gefährlich werden kann bei Standards. Also das ist keine Absteigermannschaft, die ich gesehen habe, auf keinen Fall. Und ich habe sie als Aufstiegskandidaten getippt, das könnte eng werden. Da müsste Uwe Rösler schon mit seinem Punkteschnitt bislang weitermachen, dann könnte es noch klappen, weil jetzt ist ziemlich gut der Punkteschnitt. Und man kann davon halten, was man will, aber auch seine Art verfängt ja auch. Also er ist entführt auch wieder, rausgerannt und hat da vor dem Gestirrbox seinen Jubel-Tanz aufgeführt. Und dann ist es VfL. Ich war gerade noch im Pressepistool, habe mir einen Kaffee geholt. Und dann plötzlich habe ich ihn so laut da draußen. Dann habe ich gemerkt, ja, Uwe Rösler ist gerade zur Fan-Kurve gelaufen. Und er kam dann auch nach dem Spiel in den Kabinen gang und hat einfach in der Mixed-Zone für die Journalisten einfach einen, ich mache es nicht nach, sonst fliegen alle Hörhörer in die Ohren weg, einen, ja, reingebrüllt. Also es ist, sagen wir mal, sehr exuberantiert. Aber das kann ja nicht schaden, wenn man damit auch so ein, es ist trotzdem ein euphorisches Umfeld, sondern ein leicht zu begeisterndes Umfeld in Bochum, wenn man das damit wieder ein bisschen anzündet. Also, nee, da werden andere Vereine bis zum Ende gegen den Abstieg spielen als der VfL.
Das macht ein bisschen die Bo-Henriksen-Vibes. Aus der letzten Saison. Ich glaube, niemand möchte Bo-Henriksen-Vibes aus dieser Saison haben, weil, ich sag mal so, ich sehe durchaus auch Ähnlichkeiten von Mainz 05 und der Spielvereinigung Fürth, außer dass Fürth nicht in der Conference League spielt und in anderthalb Wochen zu gleich posen muss.
Dann möchte ich auch nicht.
Komisch. Nee, also generell würde ich sagen, ich bin, also ich glaube, es ist vielen emotional gerade eben auch. Uwe Rösler natürlich auch der absolute Gegenpol zu Davor Dieter Hecking. Da könnten auch nicht mehr Welten zwischendurch liegen. Ich bin halt immer so ein bisschen vorsichtig. Das mag daran liegen, dass sich solche Art Trainer mich irgendwie einfach nicht so bekommen. Genauso bei Lukas Kwaßniok oder so. Ich finde das irgendwie immer so ein bit too much, auch da immer mit kurzer Hose zu stehen. Keine Ahnung, ist mir ein bisschen zu viel. Aber man muss halt einfach sagen, also das, was wir vor der Saison oder auch im Laufe der Saison kritisiert haben, dass man auch das Gefühl hat, der Kader, der funktioniert überhaupt nicht zusammen. Da hängen keine... Die Mannschaftsteile funktionieren überhaupt nicht. Die Neuverpflichtungen funktionieren nicht. Stand jetzt, sage ich, wenn Alfa Rubrecht jetzt auch noch anfängt, Tore zu schießen, dann wird es auch nochmal weiter eng, weil gerade er und Unieker natürlich auch gerade in diesem 4-2-3-1-System, was Rösler eigentlich so fest etabliert hat. Ich glaube, er hat nur im Pokal gegen Augsburg mit einem 4-1-1-System gespielt. Es klappt einfach ganz gut, eben schneller Außenspieler zu haben. Du hast ein festes Zentrum und dann hast du eine Spitze vorne. Das funktioniert sehr gut. Ich war auch nicht davon ausgegangen, dass Bochum jetzt unten drin bleibt. Es stand jetzt Platz 12, 16 Punkte, 20 zu 20 Tore. Man gleicht sich da eben gerade ein bisschen auf. Es hat halt eben noch die Hypothek von acht Niederlagen, aber inzwischen eben auch fünf Siege und in den letzten fünf Spielen drei Siege und entschieden eine Niederlage. Dieses Spiel gegen Dresden kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht erklären, bevor wir über den Dynamo gleich noch sprechen. Aber ja, also wie gesagt, Punkteschnitt von 2,29. Michi, du hast eben gesagt, das ist ein sehr guter Punkteschnitt. Das ist die Zahl dazu. Und ja, also ich bin mal gespannt. Ich weiß noch nicht so ganz, was passiert, wenn bei Bochum dann doch noch mal auch unter Rößler eine Niederlagenserie eintritt, weil da, wo es emotional hochgehen kann, kann es emotional eben auch sehr schnell wieder runtergehen. Das ist eben das Problem. Aber ich glaube, sie sind jetzt erstmal aus dem Größten raus. Ich sehe trotzdem weiterhin nicht– also es hatten Leute, die ja auch als Aussteiger getippt. Ich glaube, das ist eine Konsolidierung. So geht das Wort nicht. Egal. Für mich ist es die 800. Stunde heute.
Konsolidierung.
Dankeschön. Konsolidierung. Dankeschön. Voll freundlich von dir. Das heißt, erstmal schauen– wir haben es schon oft gesehen, dass es eben auch nochmal sehr viel schlimmer kommen kann als Absteiger. Von daher ist es, glaube ich, erstmal– es lässt sich viel über Kiel sagen gleichzeitig. Und ich glaube, da sind sie jetzt schon in einem ruhigeren Fahrwasser angekommen. Und auch da noch eine Info. Auch da war die Jahreshauptversammlung Tis the Season. Wer mehr dazu wissen will, dem empfehle ich jetzt einfach mal ganz richtig die Episode des 1848 Podcasts. Die Folge verlinke ich euch in den Show Notes, aber die können euch mehr darüber erzählen, was es da vielleicht auch für Neuerungen geben soll. Es steht jetzt eben mal dieses Highlight-Spiel an, zu Hause im DFB-Vokal gegen den VfB Stuttgart. Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf, ehrlich gesagt. Einfach mal gucken, was Stuttgart so bei eigenen Standards macht, dann könnte das ganz gut werden. Und dann zu Hause gegen Aminia Bielefeld, da freue ich mich am Samstag doch drauf. Ganz uneigennützig hoffe ich auf so eine richtig, richtig schwierige Partie gegen Stuttgart. Warum wohl? Weiß niemand. Na ja, habt ihr zu den beiden Teams noch zu sagen oder wollen wir zum letzten Spiel springen?
Meinetwegen können wir springen.
Sehr schön.
Springen wir.
Ja, springen wir aus dem Fürther Loch heraus nach Dresden. Na ja, da hat Dresden Fortuna Düsseldorf empfangen. Und dieses Spiel 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Tore von Rossipal und Fermé ausgerechnet, möchte man sagen. Sagt übrigens auch der Fortuna Social Media Manager, ich glaube auf X noch, das ausgerechnet Fermé, ja das 2-0 machte Rasmussen. Der trifft zwar noch spät für die Fortuna, reicht aber am Ende nicht. Und es kommt eher noch dicke für Dynamo Dresden, denn Torhüter Krüll, Grill verletzt sich stark, wird wegen schwerer Knieverletzung mehrere Monate fehlen. Und obwohl dann einer der Feldspieler der Dresden da ins Tor muss, weil kein Wechsel mehr frei war, kann Düsseldorf daraus nichts mehr machen. Das ist jetzt der zweite Sieg in Folge für die Dresdener, eben nach dem 1-0-Sieg beim VfL Bochum, ein 2-1-Heimaufwärm gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf, gerade glaube ich in der Tabellenkonstellation nicht so schlecht. Michi, ich würde mal mit dir anfangen. Es gibt auch ein Thema neben dem Platz, das würde ich jetzt erst mal kurz noch nach hinten schieben. Findest du denn, dass Dresden jetzt doch langsam zeigt, was sie in der 2. Liga leisten könnten?
Ganz offensichtlich. Man kann sagen, Dynamo lebt. Das ist ja die schönste Erkenntnis für alle Menschen, deren Herz an Dynamo Dresden hängt. Also es sah lange dann schon traurig aus. Ich habe sie am ersten Spieltag in Fürth sehen. Da haben sie, fand ich, auch immer schlechte Ansätze gehabt, auch fußballerisch. Da hatte ich damals Sorgen um die Defensive. Jetzt haben sie von allen Teams unten im Tabellenkehler die beste Torreferenz. Das haben sie auch ein bisschen in den Griff bekommen. Und klar, sie haben gewonnen in Bochum, die vor dem Spieltag 13 Punkte hatten und haben jetzt gewonnen gegen Bochum und Düsseldorf, die ebenfalls im Tabellenkehler feststecken. Also damit gegen zwei unmittelbare Konkurrenten gewonnen. Das sind Siege, die vielleicht sogar doppelt wichtig sind, auch wenn sie erst mal nur drei Punkte bringen. Aber sie bringen ja auch mindestens mal keine Punkte für die andere Mannschaft, die unten drin hängt. Insofern, klar, die Verletzung von Lennart Krillers so angesprochen, die tut schon weh. Man hat mit ihm einen Torhüter gefunden, das wurde nachher auch so betont, der wirklich auch Sicherheit ausstrahlt. Herr Anna und ich werden uns wundern, dass er das bei Dynamo so tun kann, weil in Braunschweig und in Fürth hat er das nicht immer getan. In Fürth hat jetzt nicht so viel gespielt, aber da war er als Ersatztorhüter hier, aber hat jetzt auch nicht immer die glücklichste Figur abgegeben. Bei Dynamo kann das offenbar, gönne ich ihm auch, nach doch langer Leidenszeit an verschiedenen Standorten. Aber er war für Dynamo ein guter Torhüter, der fällt jetzt erstmal aus und vermutlich auch länger. Also so wie die, ich meine, ich sehe ihn nicht nochmal sehen, die tat wirklich beim Zuschauen schon weh und hat Dynamo und er selbst, haben sie beide auch dann erwähnt, dass es vermutlich eine längere Ausfallzeit sein wird. Aber man kann sagen, die Moral stimmt auf jeden Fall. Und man hat halt jetzt in dem Spiel gesehen, es war der erste Heimsieg, das ist auch krass. Also wenn man dieses Stadion sieht, diese Begeisterungsfähigkeit, gefühlt gibt es jedes Spiel eine Ikoria im Kaplok und seit 25.000 Menschen schreien sich die Seele aus dem Leib. Das kann schon noch ein Vorteil im Abstiegskampf sein, wenn man jetzt auch schafft, zu Hause da dann Gegner zu bezwingen. Die Torreferenz habe ich gerade schon genannt mit den Minus 6. Ich habe auch schon ein bisschen Sorge, am 17. Januar zum Rückgrundenauftakt spielt Fürth bei Dynamo Dresden. Dresden ist jetzt in Form mit einem lautstarken Rudolf-Hawik-Stadion und mit einer gewissen Wucht. Schauen wir mal. Aber ich glaube für alle Dresdnerinnen und Dresdner eine sehr schöne 2 Wochen jetzt, oder eine schöne Woche, zwischen diesen beiden Fußballspielen.
Ich bin tatsächlich mal sehr gespannt, weil eine defensive Stabilität, die am Anfang nicht da war, die dann irgendwann kam, wenn betont wird, Grill, ist schon so Backup. Ich möchte jetzt dem Ersatztorhüter von Dresdner gar nicht zu nahe treten, aber es ist natürlich schon eine Frage, ob man sich so weit stabilisiert hat, dass die Kette davor das auffangen kann, oder dass man sagt, was passiert jetzt, wenn wir einen neuen Torhüter drin haben, man muss sich erstmal einspielen. Das dauert vielleicht kurz, ob da diese gleiche Stabilität wiederkommt, oder ob man da eventuell ein alter Muster verfällt. Es ist natürlich viel, ja, hätte, wenn und aber. Aber da wäre jetzt gerade ein Punkt, dass, wie gesagt, diese Verletzung von Spielern ist sowieso nie cool, aber die kommen vielleicht wirklich zum genau falschen Zeitpunkt, ehrlich gesagt, weil du so ein leichtes Aufwärts hast. Anna, Dresden ist ja in zwei Spielen, also man spielt jetzt erst zu Hause gegen den FCK, äh, auswärts beim FCK und dann eben zu Hause gegen Braunschweig. Also es gibt dieses Aufeinandertreffen, was kannst du schon mal so vielleicht ankündigen, was du dafür ein Spiel erwartest? Einfach, einfach mal so als Wild-Gaz in den Raum geworfen.
Na, ich bin tatsächlich sehr gespannt, weil sich das ja jetzt am letzten Wochenende sehr gezeigt hat, wie wichtig wirklich jeder Punkt ist, wenn ich die Phrase Dreschen drauf, wie wichtig der Sieg für die Braunschweige Eintracht war, weil die Konkurrenz halt einfach nachgezogen hat oder, ja, bis auf Fürth, Entschuldigung, ich wollte nicht aus Versehen, hier Salz in Wunden streuen, habe ich aber gemacht. Ja, das Spiel, ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Braunschweige Eintracht sich wegentwickeln möchte von Hinten stehen, warten, kontern und denke, dass wir auf eine Mannschaft treffen, die gerne spielt, die gerne das Spiel gestaltet, was ich für einen Aufsteiger gar nicht so gewöhnlich finde. Wir haben ja auch wirklich sehr ordentliche Leistungen gesehen von Dynamo Dresden gegen Hannover 96 beispielsweise, 2-2, auch gegen Elbersberg 2-2 gespielt. Also nur weil die da im unteren Bereich der Tabelle stehen, heißt das nicht, dass sie ihre Füße nicht sortiert bekommen. Und gehe davon aus, dass das ein Spiel sein wird, das wirklich sehr offen ist. Also kann ich jetzt im Vorfeld nicht ausmachen, wer da in meinen Augen der Favorit sein könnte. Weil ich glaube, dass beide, wie es so schön heißt, den Abstiegskampf angenommen haben und sich da durchaus aufopferungsvoll geben werden, um nicht zuletzt, irgendwie auch im vorletzten Spiel des Jahres vielleicht noch ein paar Punkte zu sammeln und dann eben auch vielleicht ein bisschen Abstand zur Konkurrenz aufbauen zu können. Das werden sehr, sehr spannende Wochen für den Tabellenkeller.
Ja, da würde ich mitgehen. Einmal, ich habe eben einmal schon erwähnt, dass es Vorfallen neben dem Platz gab. Es gab rassistische Ausfälle von Teilen des Dresdner Publikums gegenüber Emanuel Iyoa von Fortuna Düsseldorf. Muss man erstens sagen, sehr gut reagiert vom Schiedsrichter gespannt. Die haben eben den 3-Stufen-Plan aktiviert. Es gab eine Durchsage im Stadion unter anderem und man muss sagen, erstens sehr gute Reaktion von Thomas Stamm, also dem Trainer von Dynamo Dresden im Anschluss. Ich lese einmal kurz vor, was er genau gesagt hat. Ich habe die Bitte an diese Zuschauer, nicht mehr ins Stadion zu kommen. Sie haben mir nichts verloren, aber auch grundsätzlich nichts in der Gesellschaft. So etwas macht mich sprachlos. Die Leute können daheim bleiben und die, die drum herum sitzen, können so mutig sein, damit man weiß, wer es ist. Das finde ich tatsächlich ein enorm gutes Statement von Stamm, weil mich das manchmal stört, wenn Leute dann einfach nur sagen, ja das gehört hier nicht ins Stadion. Nee, es ist nämlich genau das. Das sollte nirgendwo in der Gesellschaft Platz haben. Und eben auch dieser Aufruf, sich dagegen zu äußern. Merke vielleicht manchmal auch, Thomas Stamm war in Freiburg lange, ist da eben natürlich auch, glaube ich, auch sensibilisiert worden, anders nochmal für das Thema. Aber auch Dynamo hat danach bei X geschrieben, dieses Zitat bedarf keiner weiteren Erklärung, Love, Dynamo, Hate, Racism. Bevor wir gleich zu den Aussagen von Markus Anfang auf der anderen Seite kommen, der ungefragter, sich, glaube ich, eher ein wenig in, ja gut gesagt, die Scheiße geritten hat, muss ich einfach sagen, ich meine, ich habe Dresden die letzten zwei Jahre eben als Gegner mitverfolgt. Es war natürlich gerade gegen Markus Anfang, den Ex-Trainer, der halt eben es nicht geschafft hat, zwei Jahre in Folge mit Dynamo Dresden aufzusteigen. Ich habe reinfilmt, für ein, zwei Dynamo-Fans war das vielleicht auch noch mal eine– oder auch für Dynamo-Spieler war das noch mal eine extra Portion, Motivation. Aber ich muss generell einfach sagen, also das, was Dresden auch zum Teil gespielt hat, das war das, was sie in der 3. Liga auch schon stark gemacht haben, was sie eben nicht immer geschafft haben, in der 2. Liga auf den Platz zu bringen, wo man halt durchaus zu Recht schon gefragt hat, haben sie genug Qualität für die 2. Liga auf dem Rasen? Haben sie da Verfehlungen gemacht in der Transfer-Fenster eben auch oder in der Transferphase? Per se ist das, glaube ich, ihr habt es gesagt, mit dem Rudolf-Hawik-Stadion, das kann immer in beide Richtungen gehen, das merkt man auch immer. Also das kann eine absolute Faustwand sein, es kann ja aber auch, ehrlich gesagt, das Leben noch ein bisschen schwerer machen. Gerade jetzt, ich glaube, sie tragen eben, sind eben auch noch auf dieser Ausstiegseuphorie, sieht das ganz gut aus. Generell bin ich mal gespannt. Also sie sind jetzt eben über einen Strich auf Platz 15. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, ob sie das halten können. Ich meine, sie waren, ich kann das ja auch sagen, sie waren ja auch bei mir Abstiegskandidat, weil ich mir eben nicht vorgestellt habe, dass sie es über die 34 Spieltage schaffen, sich da anzupassen. Aber momentan zeigt da die Formkurve auch auf jeden Fall nach oben und ich weiß, ich sag das immer, ihr könnt es alle nicht mehr hören, aber es ist einfach so, gerade in einer Situation eine Serie aufzubauen. Ich glaube, das wird denen ganz gut tun. Und Braunschweig hat ja gerade zum Beispiel beim FCK die Fehler offengelegt. Spielweisen kann man nicht vergleichen, von daher würde ich nicht sagen, das kannst du eins zu eins übertragen, aber das war ganz ordentlich bisher in dem Spiel.
Ja, das stimmt. Das kann man, denke ich, so festhalten. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich denke, Kaiserslautern ist für Ausschläge nach oben und unten bekannt. Und Dresden jetzt mit zwei Siegen im Rücken, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das spannend wird. Also, ich finde, die 2. Liga funktioniert sowieso über vor allem Serien. Also, im Prinzip brauchst du ja nur 3, 4 immerhin Siegesserien und du hältst die Klasse. Und oft ist es ja auch so, dass es nicht so ein kompletter Fleckenteppich von Siegniederlage unentschieden ist, sondern dass halt die Mannschaften, die die Klasse halten, einfach über längere Zeiten ihre Siege einfahren und am Ende haut es irgendwie hin. Wer weiß, vielleicht war jetzt das Wochenende tatsächlich der ausschlaggebende Punkt dafür, dass Dresden in die Spur nach oben findet und Kaiserslautern jetzt bis zum Winter ein bisschen schlingert. Es ist ja auch kein Umfeld ohne Erwartungshaltung. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da vielleicht ein bisschen Höhenangst zwischenzeitlich aufgekommen ist, wenn man zu viel von ganz oben geträumt hat.
Ja, und von ganz oben geträumt ist ehrlich gesagt auch ein gutes Stichwort, führt dann auch den letzten Verein, über den wir sprechen, mit Michael, aufzulachen. Ihr baut mir meine Vorlagen hier.
Ich musste nur an meine Aufstiegstipps denken. Ein Buchum, Düsseldorf und so. Die waren da alles sehr weit oben. Deswegen sollte man sich nicht als Fußball-Experten bezeichnen.
Auf jeden Fall soll es eben um Fortuna Düsseldorf gehen. Da ist es Platz 14. Also sie stehen noch über Dynamo Dresden. 14 Punkte in der Formtabelle. Zuletzt ist man allerdings auf Platz 15. Und sowieso allgemein zuletzt jetzt nicht so das Beste. Also man hat 3 Siege erst geholt. 4 Siege geholt bei unentschieden 8 Niederlagen. Das ist enorm viel. Und wir haben ja glaube ich vor einem Monat schon mal darüber gesprochen. Und man muss sagen, so wahnsinnig viel hat sich jetzt nicht verbessert. Unter Markus Anfang. Erst ein Sieg gegen den ersten FC Magdeburg, da haben wir schon darüber gesprochen. War jetzt auch nicht so, dass man sagen muss, das müssen sie unbedingt gewinnen. Dann gab es noch einen unentschiedenen Kaiserslautern. Sonst hat man alle Spiele verloren. Anna, ich sehe im Unterschied zu Daniel Tune keinerlei Verbesserung in dem Kader. Lass uns erst einmal ein bisschen auf Sportliche gucken. Woran hapert es für dich denn, vor allem bei Fortuna momentan?
Ja, an allem. Ich finde, der auffälligste Spieler ist immer wieder Florian Kastenmaier, weil ich bei ihm so am ehesten das Gefühl habe, der wehrt sich so richtig gegen das, was da gerade einfach ist und seit Wochen auch ist. Auf dem Platz und lautstark und mit Gestik und Körpersprache. Und die übrige Mannschaft wirkt jetzt– also natürlich sind die da und irgendwie machen sie auch mit, aber es wirkt, finde ich, kolossal, ich weiß gar nicht, irgendwie sowas wie unsortiert oder– also ich habe nicht das Gefühl. Dass da was passiert oder dass sich da was verändert oder auch nicht, dass da Fehlerquellen gefunden worden sind, die jetzt irgendwie nach und nach behoben werden. Sondern habe das Gefühl, dass es eher, dass die Mannschaft jetzt nach dem Trainerwechsel so ein bisschen auf sich zurückgeworfen wird, so nach dem Motto, naja, jetzt ist ja der Trainer weg. An dem hat es gelegen, jetzt müsste es ja funktionieren. Und nehme die Mannschaft als sehr, ja, also ungefährlich, würde ich sagen, wahr. Also es ist tatsächlich nicht das, was beide Trainer beschrieben haben nach dem Spiel gegen Dresden. Also wurde ja gesagt, es sei ausgeglichen gewesen und so weiter und so fort. Aber wenn man da jetzt so ein bisschen in vage Fahrwasser gehen darf, habe ich ein ganz anderes Gefahrengefühl, wenn wir über Dynamo Dresden sprechen im Vergleich zu Fortuna Düsseldorf.
Wir haben ja vor einigen Minuten schon über einen Verein gesprochen, mit dem man sich Sorgen machen muss. Ich glaube, auch um Düsseldorf muss man sich Sorgen machen. Im Forum hat dankenswerterweise ein User– ich glaube, er war männlich– die Formtabelle anders dargestellt, nämlich eine Anfangstabelle. Und damit ist in der ESMEN von sechs Spielen vier Punkte, fünf zu acht Tore auf Rang 17 in der Marcos Anfangstabelle. Und schlechter ist nur ein mir ganz gut bekannter Verein, der es noch schafft, die Fortuna zu unterbieten. Aber wenn Fürth nicht so schlecht wäre wie in den letzten Monaten, dann wäre man da auf Platz 18 und das nach einem Trainerwechsel. Also man hat ja den ersten Joker einer Mannschaft, die vielleicht nicht so performt, wie man das will, schon gezogen und steht jetzt schlechter da in der Tünetabelle, weil man deutlich weiter oben. Klar, man hat da ein Muster erkannt. Ich habe Düsseldorf auch letztes Jahr spielen sehen. Wir hatten das Thema auch schon öfter mal in diesem Format besprochen, dass da auch Spiele dabei waren, bei denen es mich wirklich gewundert hat. Und Daniel Tune dann irgendwann auch fast schon verzweifelt wirkte, manchmal auch ratlos wirkte. Trotzdem hat die Fortuna und die immer eine bessere Figur abgegeben, als es jetzt unter Markus Anfang tut. Natürlich ist eine sportlich und das andere auch, was die Außendarstellung angeht, Eva. Das wolltest du auch noch besprechen.
Ja, das sage ich gleich, ich muss eine Ergänzung noch machen. Also man muss auch sagen, mit Matthias Zimmermann, der schon Urfortuna was ist, möchte ich sagen, also seit 2018 im Verein fehlt jemand auf der rechtsverteidiger Position, weil Gell-Lunder fehlt, auch auf der rechtsverteidiger Position. Und mit Sotiris Alexandropoulos hast du auch einen Spieler, der die ersten neun Spiele durchgespielt hat und seitdem Muskelbündel hat und auch bis zum Ende des Jahres, also der ist in der Rückrunde wieder fit. Also das kommt eben auch dazu. Aber ich finde auch einfach, wenn du zum Beispiel auf das 1 zu 2 von Rasmussen guckst, also Rasmusens Gästik auch, das ist so er selbst so nach dem Tor so ein bisschen so ja, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, machen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr oder kommt da nichts? Und das finde ich so, ja natürlich kann man nicht alles über Körpersprache erzählen und darauf will ich diesen Sport auch überhaupt nicht begrenzen. Aber das ist so, also ich meine ihr zieht ja auch die Parallelen zu eurem Verein. Ich muss auch einfach sagen, ich habe sowas auch alle schon bei Bielefeld gesehen. Also einfach dieses, ja eigentlich müssten wir ja besser sein als das und wir haben ja Qualität und ja da hatten wir auch mal ein bisschen Pech. Aber das reicht nicht. Also einfach zu sagen, naja aber vom Selbstverständnis her wird es schon nicht der Abstiegskampf. Dann in meiner Anna, du hast es glaube ich eben so schön gesagt, zwei Mannschaften, die den Abstiegskampf angenommen haben. Ich sehe das bei Fortuna Düsseldorf nicht. Ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, welcher Spieler es war, aber ich meine von, da gab es eben auch die Aussage, ja wir brauchen eh erst ab dem 20. Spieltag auf die Tabelle zu gucken. Ja, also wenn du, ist natürlich nicht der Fall, aber wenn du am 20. Spieltag abgeschlagen 18er bist, dann brauchst du nicht ab da auf die Tabelle zu gucken. Also weil dann geht es nämlich nach unten. Und das finde ich halt so fatal. Und ich muss jetzt gerade kurz das Original-Statement noch von Markus Anfang raussuchen, weil ich es mir hier natürlich nicht reinkopiert habe, so professionell wie ich bin. Gebt mir zwei Sekunden. Und zwar hieß es da zu dem Vorfall bei Dynamo, again, sein eigener Spieler ist betroffen, wenn der ein oder andere aus irgendeiner Emotion reinruft, das ist nicht schön, aber das dann zur Verallgemeinern ist auch ein bisschen schwierig. Das hilft unserem Fußball nicht und ist auch nicht schön für den Menschen.
Und das ganz kurz hat er ungefragt im Sky-Interview gesagt. Also es ist nicht– und das finde ich wichtig, wirklich doppelt zu unterstreichen –,Dass da niemand gesagt hat, wie sehen Sie das denn oder haben Sie da eine Meinung zu? Sondern er ist im nächsten Redeblock noch einmal reingegangen, um zu erwähnen, was du gerade zitiert hast. Und das finde ich– also wäre auch nicht besser, wenn er zum Dresdner Verein gehören würde. Aber ich finde es noch absurder in dem Moment, in dem er einfach die rhetorische Möglichkeit hätte, selbst wenn in seinem Kopf und um Gottes Willen, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, aber irgendwie eine leichte Tendenz in Richtung Unterstützung dessen, was da geäußert wurde, wo vorherrscht, hätte er einfach die Chance zu sagen, mein Spieler tut mir leid. Also es sind so viele Wege, das einfach smart zu lösen, wenn man sich da nicht zu äußern möchte. Und er hat keinen davon gefunden.
Ja, vor allem, ich weiß auch gar nicht, was er mit Menschen meint. Meint er da Ijoa mit? Oder meint er die Person, die rassistisch beleidigt hat? Also mit der habe ich an der Stelle vor allem sehr wenig mitleid. Und also, ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob Anfang da irgendwie versucht hat, eine Beziehung noch zu den Dresden-Fans zu kitten. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass es gut ankommt, so zu versuchen. Und man muss einfach sagen, also alleine immer, ich muss das an der Stelle nochmal deutlich sagen, Rassismus ist keine Emotion. Wenn dir aus der Emotion heraus etwas Diskriminierendes rausrutscht, ob das sexistisch, queerfeindlich oder rassistisch ist, dann ist das keine Emotion, sondern dann bist du eben ein Rassist, ein Sexist oder queerfeindlich. So. Und ich kann es nicht mehr hören, so was mit Emotionen zu entschuldigen. Und natürlich ist nicht ein ganzes Stadion an einer Person schuld. Und sowas wird es, auch wenn andere Vereine das nicht hören, es wird auch auf St. Pauli solche Rufe geben. Es ist natürlich immer der Unterschied, wie die Menschen drum herum reagieren. Und wir haben eben Thomas Stamm dafür gelobt, was er danach sagt. Und das zu hören und dann zu sagen, nee, ich muss das jetzt irgendwie anders frameen. Und wenn das dein Trainer ist und dein Trainer soll dich als Spieler schützen und alle schützen dich als Spieler außer dein eigener Trainer, ich hätte keinen Bock mehr unter dem zu spielen. Also das muss man einfach so sagen, wenn das das ist, was was rausgetragen wird und man kann ihm das nicht positiv einsehen und das hat auch nichts mit Verallgemeinerung zu tun, das ist einfach eine Katastrophe. Und das, ich meine, und dann muss man wirklich leider einfach sagen, ich weiß, dass immer wieder gesagt wurde, ja, aber diese Impfdebatte und etc. und PP und das soll man Markus Anfang doch nicht ewig nachtagen. Aber Markus Anfang in nichts, was er tut, spricht er dafür, dass man ihn auch neben dem Platz, als jemanden wahrnimmt, der, und das muss ich so hart sagen, auch junge Spieler beispielsweise entwickeln sollte, weil da– ne, also sorry für den emotionalen Ausbruch, aber sowas macht mich wirklich unfassbar sauer.
Ja, und ich finde das umso bemerkenswerter. Hatte mich damals schon über die Verpflichtung gewundert, gerade von den Hintergründen, die du gerade noch mal skizziert hast, weil ja Fortuna Düsseldorf mit so Kampagnen wie Fortuna für alle, freier Eintritt ins Stadion, erst mal nur für ein paar Spiele. Aber perspektivisch war eigentlich die Vision, halt barrierefreier im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, auch zahlungsfreier Zugang zum Stadion. Und das ist ja ein riesiges Statement, also das alle und auch zu anzuerkennen, dass es einfach für Leute schwer ist, sich ein Ticket zu leisten und so weiter und so fort. Also so der inklusive Überbau, wenigstens als Idee, den mal zu formulieren oder auch mal so einer Utopie nachzugehen. Und das, finde ich, steht in einem absurden Kontrast zu dieser Trainerposition. Das habe ich nicht verstanden und wirft umso mehr Fragen auf nach diesen Äußerungen jetzt am Wochenende, da würde ich mich dir in allen Punkten anschließen wollen, wirklich unsäglich finde und irgendwie mich dann auch frage, wie kommt das an bei dem Spieler, der da betroffen ist, bei der Mannschaft, die wahrscheinlich ihrem Mannschaftskameraden gegenüber solidarischer ist, als dem Trainer, der seit 6 Wochen da ist. Aber auch, wie bereitest du das als PR-Mensch auf? Wie gehst du mit so einer Personalie um? Das ist wirklich ein einziges Desaster.
Und daran anschließend auch noch, ich glaube, dass da wirklich extrem viel kaputtgegangen ist, man mehr verloren hat als ein Fußballspiel. Das eine ist das Binnenverhältnis, auch Mannschafts-Trainer. Dass man Menschen nicht schützt, dass da ein Mensch, der rassistisch beleidigt wurde, einfach keine Rückendeckung von seinem Trainer erfährt. Aber die Fortuna-Fanszene ist ja auch tendenziell eine sehr progressive und die sich gegen sehr viele Diskriminierungsformen einsetzt. Und wenn der eigene Trainer dann den Rassismus verharmlost und sportlich keinen Erfolg hat, kann das, glaube ich, auch schnell für ihn unangenehm werden. Was natürlich dann eine Rolle spielt, wenn vor allem die Ultra-Gruppen in Düsseldorf ganz klare politische Statements auch immer wieder setzen, was ja sehr schön und sehr erfreulich ist. Also, ein Gefallen hat sich Markus Anfang damit auf keinen Fall getan. Wird er wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch gemerkt haben, aber die Vielzahl an Ausfällen, die er sich leistet, da kann man irgendwann auch nicht mehr an Zufälle glauben. Also, entweder ist er schlecht beraten oder er kann und will es dann einfach nicht besser können. Aber beides sind keine guten Erkenntnisse. Und ja, wie Anna vorhin sagte, vielleicht ist dann da die Hoffnung, dass das mit schon einem Trainerwechsel in Düsseldorf, dass da eine Mannschaft bis zum Ende unten mitspielen wird, die dafür sorgt, dass ich nicht im April schon weiß, wer abgestiegen ist.
Ja, ich würde sagen, es wird spannend zu sehen sein, weil ich glaube, wir sind uns da auch alle einig darüber, dass Klaus Alofs da natürlich auch– wir haben ja schon mal drüber gesprochen– aber da natürlich gleichzeitig auch mit den Mittelpunkt rückt, weil er hat dann den Tune entlassen, er hat Markus Anfang verpflichtet. Ja, wo geht das auch ein bisschen, möchte ich sagen, auf seine Kappe. Und von daher im Endeffekt natürlich auch zuständig für die Kaderzusammenstellung etc., PP. Von daher, ja, und ich möchte auch sagen, zu Hause gegen Schalke und auswärts bei Elbersberg sind jetzt auch nicht die Partien, die ich mir in diesem Zustand wünschen wollen würde, als Fortuna Düsseldorf.
Aber, 17. Spieltag, 17. Spieltag. Heimspiel gegen Fürth.
Ja, ja.
Ja, da müsst ihr dann ran. Das ist dann ebenso.
Du, also stand jetzt, wenn dann irgendwann dein ganzer Kader gegen dich spielt, ich glaube, da könnte Fürth noch, dann haben sie ja schon einen neuen Trainer.
Ja, tatsächlich ist es, glaube ich, kein schlechtes Timing, weil ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass Fortuna Düsseldorf sich da jetzt in den Aufwärts-Swirl reingrooved und vor Weihnachten denke ich nicht, dass du einen frisch eingestellten Trainer direkt wieder vor die Tür setzt. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das, wenn sich das fortsetzt, dass das ein sehr fruchtbarer Boden ist. Also ein Fürther fruchtbarer Boden, kein Düsseldorfer fruchtbarer Boden.
Und auch wieder ein Fortuna für alle Spiele. Mal sehen, wie das wird.
Und das verlieren sie ja meistens, wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Aber auch gut, dass da Fürth dann 1 Euro Vorverkaufsgebühr erhebt auf die Freikarten. Aber das ist wieder ein anderes Thema.
Ich glaube, bei uns waren es sogar 5 oder so. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Also das für eine Fußballspiel, das für alle Menschen umsonst sein soll, aufgrund der großen Bearbeitungsgebühren dann immer noch. Gebühren erheben ist auch schön. Aber ich glaube, das führt nach einer Stunde 42 zu weit.
Ich würde jetzt auch zu einem Rent einsetzen, dass ich 42,50 Euro für ein Bochumer Sitzplatz-Ticket bezahlen muss. Das ich sehr frech finde. Aber gut, das ist eine Gali-Grü in den Tief im Westen. Gut, ich würde einfach sagen, wir beenden an der Stelle zumindest schon mal den sportlichen Teil. Ich habe noch ein bisschen Housekeeping für euch. Einmal. Ich habe leider noch kein genaues Datum für euch. Aber die nächste Sendung, die wird kurz vor Weihnachten stattfinden. Es wird einen hinrundenden Rückblick geben mit Marc und mir. Ein bisschen analog zur Vorschau und dem ersten Spieltag. Wir werden nicht jeden Verein in 80 Minuten ungefähr besprechen. Also, weil so viel Zeit habe ich nicht vor Weihnachten. Ich denke mal, wir werden da auch analog wieder die Spiele durchgehen. Also, wenn ihr da Input habt etc., dann bitte rein ins Forum. Gerne auch schon mal sammeln. Sonst natürlich der Hinweis, wie immer, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, payroll- und sponsorenfrei. Der stellvertretende Dank an SupporterInnen geht heute an Jan T., Rasta Ari, René vom Eintracht Podcast, Fried Frank und Jan. Danke, dass ihr bereits Rasenfunk-UnterstützerInnen seid. Wenn ihr mal mehr darüber wissen wollt, dann guckt einfach mal in den Show Notes vorbei. Da sind alle wichtigen Seiten verlinkt. Außerdem ist heute eben die Sendung zur Bundesliga, der Männer erschien, in der Nacht auf Mittwoch. Er scheint, dass die Sendung zum Länderspiel der Frauen, zum Final-Four-Finale, wow, also der Nations League, da geht es ja morgen Abend im Rückspiel gegen Spanien. Und eventuell scheint noch ein Schwerpunkt diese Woche, das soll ich aber auch von Max ausrichten. Das ist noch nicht so ganz klar. Und dann bleibt mir tatsächlich an dieser Stelle nur zu sagen, vielen Dank an meine Gäste, denn zum einen Anna Lautenbach, schön, dass du mit mir, mit uns in dieser Folge dabei warst.
Danke für die Einladung. Es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Und ich finde es tatsächlich immer wieder cool, eingeladen zu werden, zu nicht Braunsteig folgen, weil es einfach so die Wahrnehmung der Liga nochmal so ganz anders vertieft. Und das ist echt spannend. Vielen Dank.
Ja, und dann auch lieben Dank an Michi Fischer, der im Chaos dieses Montags, des 1.12., ich hoffe, deine restlichen Türchen des Adventskalenders werden ein bisschen harmonischer. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch harmonischer wird. Aber vielen Dank, dass du dir trotzdem auch für uns die Zeit genommen hast.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Und ich entschuldige mich nochmal für den kurzen gedankliche Chaos in meinem Kopf, was Stefanos Timas angeht. Es tut mir leid, liebe Fans, das 1. FCN ist weg.
Ach ja, den hatte ich ja auch.
Aber der Tag, der war anstrengend heute.
Ihr verzeiht uns das bitte und schaltet dann auch bei der nächsten Folge wieder ein. Ich wünsche euch sonst eine, falls ihr feiert, schöne Adventszeit und wir hören uns dann kurz vor Weihnachten wieder.
Tschüss!
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.
Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.